came from xbox now greetings all you
exploit warriors out there and welcome
to episode 999 of it came from xbox live
this is the final episode of exploit and
i am your host maximum lick bargains
here again to guide you once more into
the strange wild and the weird of xbox
indie games and on today's episode the
final episode we've got an extra just
jam-packed super-sized one put together
for you guys I got five games on here
instead of three and we've got five
different co-hosts five different ex
alums back again we're gonna have a
different one for each game it's gonna
be great once jump to the first one
right ok so we're jumping into something
a little weird I'm not entirely sure
what title of this game is supposed to
be but to help me decipher it let's
introduce our co-host for this segment
Tom please let the internet hear your
beautiful dulcet tones I think it's
called press Start button yeah I know
right there's a isn't it the official
like name on the screen was a like two
dashes and the arrow pointing to a
sideways box which may or may not be a
diamond I don't think that's what
they're called baby was this game made
by Prince ah guess he doesn't have a
name oh my gosh check it out here we go
here we go so what do you see I see I
see the end of God yeah coming down to
the earth and then there's it's almost
like photorealistic you do that here I
guess a little bit but I don't know what
we're supposed to do it's photorealistic
like ground and sky and hand but like
cartoony water and green dudes oh my god
I think you bring about whoa and you're
gonna care of them be careful now if I
were died and I was holding green to do
it immediately drop them in the crease
no I don't know what hap that's not good
nothing gonna come back here here i
think i can give you I can give you a
pro tip hot tips try to hold down down
on a stick keep pressing down look at
that oh my god i planted him you maybe
maybe try again try this guy how's he
gonna stay he go see that was something
that i put the guy in the water I don't
know I think I don't think he's coming
back put that one guys on the ground now
this guy is trying to get away he's like
I don't want any of what you're offering
I don't want you to close to the water
there you go you go look at she was
getting strategic with it he's fighting
he didn't want that well you managed to
stop the gears of war style bleed out
happy oh my god agree no no this is some
next this is some next-level oh my god
ok do it do it oh wow that was not
likely what happened keep disappearing
ready to go wasn't too much it may be me
maybe don't dump it like directly on him
maybe dump it like a little office I you
don't drown I didn't grab water yeah i'm
grabbin water you need to do better ok
so now whoa and the game's over I think
you think you might have killed a couple
of I'm doing that but one survived so
all right here we go well I'm trying to
water it but no you can just you can
just do a triple that's what I'm trying
to do what do you think what's going on
I love this background it's very easy
oh my god did it you didn't like yeah I
think you drive out okay plant the plant
this guy and dump the water straight
ominous let's go no deals like I've
sprout that's wrong guy okay please Brad
guy and then let's just go to the water
water on him straight away oh man oh my
god through the picture of a tree with
eyes you trying to pick it up wow isn't
what I expected to have why is the tree
have a face uh I guess cuz it's living
is this Legos is this like an L Gorgui
super environment I no wonder what is it
oh my gosh it's doing it again it's
doing it again this is sofas or work so
hard transition it looks great great now
you've got these two trees I got to
treat you guys to trees you don't seem
to be able to pick them up and what does
that do why would you not oh my god what
are you doing what are you doing why are
you doing this oh that's all this is
lewd this just got real got real inner
yeah really oh goodness why why why are
you doing this thing okay I think it's
oh my god rocket rocket Chuck quit what
what is happening oh my god why edit
jerk off yes Dave over are you like on a
timer what are these two meters at the
top of the screen you have all these
silver boxes and all these gold boxes
why would you make this game and not
explain anything about what's happening
because it's about discovery this is
like this is like a star seed pilgrim
that's what this game is like there see
I'll do that down there
crap
oh my god whoa one of them made it in
there okay grab that guy grab that guy
get him in there get him in now yeah oh
my god yeah same ever yes get him in
there it's about to take off look you
got some points you got 100 mm 100 and
the sequela what the hell is he what is
is there like is there any other options
or anything I want to know if like is
this the first stage or is like I know
are we failing or are we reaching the
natural conclusion of the key i don't
know i mean it was worth a dollar yeah
well worth the dollar I think that's the
whole game I really thought that is give
it like a second level it's gonna be
like a spore thing where like it opens
up and you do all oh my god evolution
there's no evolutions for its all
creative it's more creative ism
creationism creationism yeah um well
weird that we've seen all of this game
we have we have we literally beat the
entire guy was on let's play of arrow in
the box hope you guys enjoyed it we
conquered it yep done all right Sean I
think I've picked out a real winner for
you here is it Gary cyber with Jerry's
cyber with doubt the old Technicolor
saloon right next to the sheriff's good
old Gary side we go hmm two-player mode
is the best woman says random gamer here
Anna makes random gamer it's doable here
white you start act because I played a
little bit of story about how much you
plan to play some story mode there you
go you drink it in is it is the year
2xxx all the humans are dead the world
is ruled by cyborg all the humans are
dead everything changed into cyber Wild
West gory cyber West because that's all
cyborgs identify everything yeah it is
beefing never shoot to your totally he's
got a little a little baby hat and
little baby going then shoot your enemy
okay okay enough talk and let us get you
a body upgrade word body upgrade 45
minutes later there you go you're a big
body whoa oh no oh dad became
I boards a group of rough wanna tango
bring it on he said okay there's a to
skip tack because you're gonna want to
wait till wait for it disappears press
our tea or a heroic Harry versus low Joe
this is really good alright get ready
wait for it shoot him oh wow wow wow ms
what's up ms paint oh I'm gonna shoot
fat jack good ready look at the game
he's so fat he's unfair you should at
least have a shirt on he started to wear
shirt but he just couldn't quite get it
can't get all the way back I feel like
if it really was the year 2xxx then p
don't they have like any kind of body
armor is she gonna get where i just shot
a canyon into his belly he did you shall
well he shot us all guts away whoa oh
this got anything because Larry Larry
needs to you like a sandwich yeah he
does kind of all this Larry looks real
gone
okay you got a pretty face way for it oh
you have a good point what I have
different weapons chemical thorough I
feel like a flame throwers the least
efficient weapon to use in a duel that's
true cuz that it takes at least of like
a second or two the flames are really
good going whereas a gun yeah that's
pretty and you just cut yeah you just
gotta pull the trigger and it goes
ruthless Rob Bob Oh your old buddy prob
Bob Hall good old Rob Bob I'm Bob which
is hanging out in front of the
incorrectly spelled saloon the suit
saloon with this well hmm oh no I jumped
the gun wait jumped the gun rue it up I
like he's just not gonna shoot you he's
like ah you pull your trigger all right
all right before it could you even do
that too early in a real like if you
were really having a duel with somebody
and you it seems like you would want to
pull it too early right cuz they missed
you know the other guys dead yeah they
can't complain I mean they may file a
complaint against you oh if they're you
know not dead which you're having a duel
so they should be oh no debit why are
you fighting your dad dad don't fight
your dad dently dad is that you plot
twist I am evil I gotta concentrate cuz
his time is this time returning you
begin like 27 so all right here we go
you go you got it it's a punch with oh
look at that dad is that by 4
milliseconds on evil dad there you go
wow so just hey Owen zombie I thought
that least be like if you're not gonna
if you have like a little bit of a
dialogue thing about no dude is dead
yeah barely no remorse bad bird burrito
knife oh but 20 is the best time I've
ever gotten I know you are a hair
trigger okay
trigger queue with Pokemon
near true
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I need a judge over
here ma a judge on table one ah do to
get you got it dude I really like I
should go to me I know i'ma shoot this
guy in the real lean she this team I
just want to shoot one duty out session
there we go nice they're all right there
we go there you go that's Corey cyber
West ladies and gentlemen all right look
stonegate Studios veteran developers
it's a milk stone joint max no stone
jam10 away home on to handsome gameplay
Trump thing and turn off the light it's
a horror game it's spooky game you know
I hate spook got ya here we go by users
who know Chris waters know Chris waters
don't like no scary games scary games oh
okay well no matter what we got in here
me and my workmate I think that should
be there researching a story okay for
their magazine yeah so they're staying a
small town in a hotel room near the
haunted play near a plot you got to be
where the plot is a month ago puts a
little bit worries in the area no I'm
sure it's fun oh there's a spooky thing
alright let's get this over with man
Jesus do I want to play all right I will
or you can why don't you ok this is fine
folks at home may recognize this game
bears a certain resemblance to another
game now looks like seeing wonderment Oh
christus knocked it right out of the
park final play with non-inverted
controls that's the area in verse game
you can invert them we're uh when I
think about the tile screams that's fine
okay well i started a different place
all right well maybe there's a road
maybe it's like it's like a it's a rogue
light find all randomized or would all
right that's probably where I shouldn't
go you found the gate I you see the
Milky Way
no why is there a black hole at the top
oh my girl is getting sucked into the
void well we only have a few more
minutes left because the atmos before
the atmosphere is sucked up this place
that's where they are entire planet is
the Gulf into nothing there oh my
goodness the ground is growing gonna go
for jump around there you go that's a
good idea ah nope it's the street some
grass is the tree don't worry about it
oh there's another one oh I can run Oh
what I'm just practicing for later whoa
Wow was it down oh so we're gonna make
it gross oh my god oh no turn off the
light and run around in circles
aimlessly this is hey I can make
yourself get lost look just be just be
cool what do i do I think I think if you
just don't don't look at him yeah don't
look at him too long because I think it
makes you crazy and I'm trying to
remember how it works wonders so slender
if I imagine it's it's almost the exact
same ok now it's fine you're good you're
good ambien beading may be disoriented
yourself a little bit but otherwise do
not worry i had much orient to go from
and what's right it's gonna kind of
wander around here
staticky also it should be noted that we
are playing with the lights off we are
wide open you are dead why did that
happen I knew this is what being dead
would feel like what is this river I'm
river hey there's a champion I see it
I'm gonna grab it oh yes there you go
sweet delicious tape recorder okay also
feel like in slender the longer you had
the flashlight on it and get like drew
they drew the thing to you all right
they both take us back here you go just
take a little nighttime big total
nighttime dip in the pond off soothing
water oh okay does fig out Oh ruins my
company shows up how does he know the
texts are key miss there's a bridge hey
I'll tonight Ringley bridge I don't have
to Ford the river
have to float the wagon Britt Oh much
kind of like a baby like it's not a
bridge Oh God be careful that's not a
bird on a bridge it's very misleading
yeah I think it would because there's
water on the other side it's just a park
ranger yeah you just want to get close
enough to give you tips about how to
test enjoy this what is it Terry what if
that's the twist of the game like you're
actually like a crazy intruder yeah you
like the park ranger just come to
collect you like kid book come on you've
been running around out here play two
hours please the tape recorders are part
of the exhibit yeah you're just stealing
that it's kind of thing about
hummingbirds on it why do you are you
stealing the recorders it describes the
local flora and fauna just put them back
dude it's cool what is this a picture of
okay dudes aren't working real good your
eyeballs are not inside of your eye
sockets which is where they're supposed
to be a bench there you can catch your
breath know that from oh yeah let's
definitely go in this building because
that will check this thing this is
definitely gonna end well sneak them
sneak them okay cool hey my buddy art
come on couldn't draw some more iglehart
write it like look I made the eyeball
person stamp I'm not making enough wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait oh hey
nemesis this is darren side going on
drunken final space i need to smile
confined spaces i need to km away from
the bus stop hey you gotta go in that
bus stop no I'm definitely not gonna go
in the bus to know in the neck but okay
nevermind come on agha interrupt
gotcha you got this all right in and out
inside and smash and grab it's not here
not here right there right there right
there right there looks like it that
looks like it smash and grab on the door
out the door okay there we go okay small
confined places bus stop yeah all right
two more two more where would they be
wherever they feel like the bus stop is
near I was back home we were
um you you now we have to sit through a
lecture on local history all right uh so
we did our boat oh there you go cool
code got some codes gonna dunk got some
other milks to all these other fine milk
stone games you around Tony featured on
the show zombie football we did infamous
we did wait Raven cawing we did and red
invasion nice so we've done a lot of
these game millstone has had a pretty
great run on X league they have and i
gotta say thank you thank you boys and
milks Alejandro and Miguel yeah good
work and you Santiago you got your own
page buddy good job you did get avatar
picture you think it avatar picture
grant page peacing out all right Kevin
for your ex legs selection I have chosen
something real cerebro oh boy because I
remember when we played then we played
20 games players your mate we both
really enjoyed they have like a little
board game or like kind of strategy game
yeah I kicked her ass with that as i
recall i don't know if that really was
sort of like that but it to be fair we
went through about three other games
that day where you kicked my ass so so
yeah I'm glad you'd show us something
like this is right up my alley so let's
see here we should be able to do I hope
you haven't actually seems to evoke
emotes whistling you hit oh you'll have
to sign it as one of my many fine I'll
be anonymous nobody knows you're a
pretty good one all right and I think he
just hit the a button to join there we
go and then i will start us up part what
happens here now okay so it looks like
your blue and I think I'm yeah I'm pink
and green and yellow are going to be the
computers so the way this works is we
want to expand our territory into other
players territory by moving our blocks
around so you hit the a button to pick
up your blocks and then you hit that you
go to where you want to go and you hit
the a button again to move them there
um you can also spawn new blocks for
yourself by hitting the X button when
you're over one of your tile so you see
over there on the on the left hand side
it shows you how many blocks you have
like you'd up oh don't even mask at
don't even mess i'm working on a whole
thing over here we gotta get yellow all
right i'll work on yellow yeah you get
that one I'm gonna grab this one or you
can try to grab both of them she'll have
enough 14 to their 13 boo you totally
have all right now take my both you and
me it's you and me well I've sort of got
like everything's just kind of backed up
in this one spot here you can get
through the breach
oh no my forces are divided my supply
lines are broken oh no no no I want to
do this again wait to make it happen to
dig in for the final siege the final
siege hang on i'm ready dudes spawn more
overlords dug in we're doing in your
that where's my mom where's my selection
oh I guess I can't move my oh 3 is mine
I don't know uh-huh that was fun how did
that I wish people that even people
don't understand the simple pleasures of
a strategy game yeah oh can I say bad
words on the show uh yes okay it's a
[ __ ] you yellow I know yo is the word
damn it they're not even winning they're
just making everything worse who's green
now green ugly green is just greenness
the silent giant in the air oh wow that
was a big long hey
come on I got to get this ball yellow
and I are we're duking it out over here
we're committed get it you know get it
get it yes Oh go go go go go go go go go
go go go go no working in get in Oh reef
or spring force take it take it take it
take it yes yeah okay you are far more
patient than I am and that was my
downfall open spot reinforcements here
moving is up move those up all right all
right very good all right feeling good
feeling good sweep it sweep it sweep it
take take yeah oh yeah yes yeah you got
it made you gotta make you gotta make
you you did it you got it you got it may
got it just way from just come off the
cool down there we go get in get in oh I
can't move my thing around while he's in
the fight whoo yeah green Blair what's
up of all the action games we could have
been playing I did this big s we wind up
whoo that was awesome that was pretty
good here this time okay why don't you
do one well let's let you up with a game
you're gonna you're gonna play on here
no you don't climb in oh you know I'm
watching all right let's see you want to
do the land rush you're Phil hi Phil
Phil okay Phil will do will do a small
map tiny oh my god put you on normal oh
cuz we run hard life oh this is ivan e
your pink remember your pink Oh Kevin
straight out of the gate with the
aggression okay great so right now Kevin
banda would with three pink blocks to
green players five griot it's 424 it's
all tied up Oh green player with the
response 5244 24 again all tied up a
green player second player got one two
three four five six six blocks on the
field to Kevin's once your table for six
so six to six they're just going blow
for blow back and forth Kevin looking to
make purchase on this one green block
here oh no
okay good oh no oh and a big attack I
think I'm done a big set of rock horse
over oh that's gonna be yeah yo haha
tough nuggets on now I could keep
playing this all day this day I look
what you bring me in you show me these
board games type things it's like this
always works out great love stuff oh
yeah we got some other crystal but how
to play their attack and defend you go
to places reinforcing your loop you
every five seconds we know we're and
then these people good for John borough
ling wang and Eric were show thank you
those three people were making this game
is Greek yeah true
yeah oh maybe maybe press that there
goes well oh wait okay yes maximum yeah
I can't tell you how thrilled I am that
the last game I get to I get says
co-host with you on X plague is a silver
yo name of a silver dollar just they've
ascended to godhood at this point they
are so masterful exploit development
they really are let's get let's get you
in on this game actually one finger
death punch yes I like legitimately
really enjoy this game all right I've
been playing it'll just a good amount on
my own time all right let's see everyone
like any levels here most urgent will go
back to beginning here okay have you
have you started out once you start okay
there are on first level and I think it
should give you some instructions okay I
what to do because I pretty simple okay
all right see here you can install yeah
there you go to move wait okay all right
we offer a nice enter the zone learn all
right x young Padawans love the finest
MCS semi racist your voice over somewhat
offensive yeah you should old Asian man
hoist over me so basically when the guy
gets close to you on that side you want
to hit the X button there you go I think
I see where this yeah there you go yeah
baby food all right come through there
dude whoo I'm thrown into to you like
build up a multiplier holding my pliers
Oh see I want that I bet if I played my
cards more smartly yeah I'd be in
position to smash that thing over there
oh yes okay so this game is sort of pays
homage to a bunch of like flash movies
from the 90s that I would watch sure
just like stick dude beats up a hundred
other dude totally goofy choreographed
mayhem
yes yet this is very much in that stuff
this is almost exactly what it was like
especially later on because you're gonna
get to pick up like weapons and stuff
later on well I have to say it actually
it feels pretty good yeah it's like you
know in for a silver dollar gave it and
it is an actual game yeah one thing they
tried just something like why did I buy
this fri or or many of their other just
gag yeah I mean because the attacks just
looks so yeah intense that you know it
feels good it does it differ mouth
visually fast we'll do the next one do
in there Oh be in the sometimes you go
you can do the power smash oh yeah so in
the combat zone it's basically like a
ddr thing buttons are gonna come down
and you hit the button okay I think this
would make a lot more sense if the
buttons went up and down because then it
really would be like CDR interface oh
great that dude I'll see here you go you
gotta suck you got a I got a bo staff
thing now oh crap [ __ ] now you gotta do
be he's on the other side there you go I
miss oh yeah we write tiny little extra
bag comes in the beginning another big
guy he's gonna be another fun guy to be
doom aw get home light him up well boom
boom boom nice nice ah ah there you go
only
still pretty good whoa oh yeah oh yeah
whoa deco oh by the way hey don't want
people reward it bears no actionable
resemblance to any weapon from any sign
for McKinney that all right there you go
now you can have like all range this is
actually I impressed by how much I know
they were able to follow this game
players in you know such a very simple
yeah punching [ __ ] focus focus missing
leaves you open oh do do do all right
you guys okay the only thing to think
about the lights were around us there
aren't I found there aren't as many of
like the double hit enemies or the
Palisades it's just it's just speed yeah
enemies that are there are gonna run at
you really bright okay so you can like I
can hit him like twice and go on to
somebody else my god eyeball cow I ball
skills oh no I think you could like on
those three hit enemies you can like hit
him twice and then go fight somebody
else right and then come back and finish
them off oh man
I mean oh no those necklace
for that ball to this ball ball dad I
have a lot of trouble but yeah you if
you can keep it in play like on your
phone screen oh that's cool I think one
hitting enemies yeah that is cool games
got physic rent
oh my god come on max yeah oh that guy
totally do a thing at me that's just
like you know what no valiant valiant
effort though all right that was pretty
good yeah that's one finger death punch
know is I have to say max for my final
your silver dome as a participant as a
co-host of came from xbox live you my
friend could not have selected a grander
good eight grandeur game with a more
fitting game and thank you it's been an
honor to noon it's been an honor and a
privilege sharing this couch with you
yes over the runways a journey came from
xbox live so many sort of good games yes
and really weird games and you know
we'll always have fish listening to a
radio alright folks well that's gonna
just about do it for the entire series
of it came from xbox live thank you all
so much out there for tuning in and
watching the show and for suggesting
indie games for me to check out I've had
a lot of fun putting this together
picking out the different games showing
them off to you guys I honestly I hope
you guys out there had as much fun
watching it as I had putting it together
because this was a really fun project
for me um I want to give a big thanks to
Carolyn and all the other exploit
co-hosts that have been on the show I
usually just run and grab them like
super last-minute have them come in here
in record so I appreciate them being
accommodating to me for all that and a
big shout-out and an extra big thanks to
all the exploit developers out there
whether we rift on your game or we
praised it or we liked it or we didn't
like it or whatever just the fact that
you guys like actually finish these
games and got them up on exploit and
actually made them available for the
public is just an amazing feat in itself
so whether we liked it or we didn't like
it it's a great accomplishment all the
same so you know
big triple decker thank you to everybody
out there we'll go ahead and just cut it
there i'm axel ohmic bargains one last
time saying see you around it came from
xbox
let's do dis oh that's Philly is this
creepier or less creepy I feel like it
well you know that doesn't remember
outlast ya know cuz it was all night
vision that game was all night vision
mode will he ever come on where you had
but yeah I was a scary game ahead the
ball no max all I will play scary games
unless I get tricked into them yeah
certain khoa for workers of mind they
should get bamboozled unless you're like
hey wanna recorded be indicated before
want to be part of the last step lose
anything ever we're just gonna play a
goofy little games gonna be historical
the games probably want to be a part of
history Oh Peter boy why do I talk like
that I don't know that's your bamboozle
invoice it is that's what I'm here to
bend in all high-pitched and goofy